[Musique]
la vie si tous quand est astucieux belle
et la furie le plus sérieux et a joué
aujourd'hui il fait mine de vouloir
prévenir sa famille
je
mais qu'est ce que tu fais tout quand
roland fabrice bonjour à tous et à
toutes
qu'est ce que mon nom et thuc encore et
je suis le seul oiseau au monde qui
tricotent mais comment ça se fait ça
parce que faut que j'habille le petit le
petitou et wii est pratique dont alors
ça c'est extraordinaire c'est beaucoup
de mal pour les points à l'endroit ah
oui c'est pas commode
dis donc oui c'est pas tout ça mais nous
avons tout de même une petite expérience
à réaliser et puis elle est facile ça me
donne faim on n'y a pas de rejet
rampillon alors oui m'enfin écoute soit
raisonnable tu vas pas en manger les
papillons devant tout le monde tout de
même vous regardez cette petite
plaquette
regardez la bien voilà et je vais vous
demander en même temps que tout cancan
d'après vous où se trouve la plus grande
distance entre la tête ici de ce
papillon et cette tête là où entre la
tête de ce papillon et la tête de celui
là à où est la plus grande distincts
c'est un cas de conscience à un cas de
conscience
je sens vous avez envie de me répondre
parce que moi j'aurais répondu ça et
tout cancan également entre ce papillon
l'a7 est là et c'est tes plats c'est ce
qu'ils sont aux yeux et manon c'est un
effet d'optique pas du tout en réalité
c'est exactement la même distance vous
allez voir si je prends ce témoin nous
constatons la distance entre ces deux
têtes et la distance entre ces deux là
est exactement la même regardez heures
c'est terrible 1 s'est trouvé
terriblement trompeur on se demande
vraiment comment cela peut se faire
c'est un effet d'optique ça arrive
souvent dans la vie méfiez-vous des
effets d'optique
voilà tout corps et qu'on désire que
j'arrête la radio ouï jamais entendu une
vaguement une radio tu sais c'est
peut-être nos voisins les fameuses
mésanges de temps en temps elles
écoutent la radio alors voilà c'est pour
ça que si nous allons jouer au mot-à-mot
ça te plaît oui oui oui oui eh ben moi
je
faisant le fond sonore il attend à mes
enfants quel bonheur
voilà le montat me vaut tellement facile
le mot tabou parce que il faut se
concentrer faut bien réfléchir
vous avez devant vous des cartons qui
évoque des objets des animaux des
personnes et c'est à chaque fois une
syllabe est tout le problème est
d'utiliser ses syllabes pour former
d'autres mots vous savez qu'ils sont
tous très fort la dernière fois je crois
que j'avais gagné si je vous dis oui
mais je me demande si parfait on ne
laisse pas passer certains vont sûrement
sûrement très jolie siens alors j'en
prends 5 comme d'habitude on d'habitude
comme france 1 1 2 3 4 et st alors sans
oui un coup oui à port lay a bien
souvent seule ville à lui remis une
chute une vue très joli but
il est d'un vert inverse ah oui
ah bah ça mais j'en ai pas la wii qu'est
ce que tu as trouvé
j'arrête je veux pas te le dire mais
j'en versant comment ça ne vous
intéresse pas en versant à 6 versant
c'est pas mal oui oui un versant inc web
et ben et ben je vais l'utiliser c'est
pas mal du tout ça hein versants de
collines
oui par exemple ben oui un versant alors
agir c'est mieux ça s'écrit comme ça un
verre sans bien jouer tout cas encore
mieux ça c'est très bien joué il ya un
versant nord où tu es ce que vous avez
autre chose moi j'arrive tout doucement
il ya rapido on aurait pu faire couvert
oui oui
alors on a réutilisé par exemple le vert
on a remis le couvert ouvert c'est bien
aussi je vais l'écrire l'inscrire
également en dessous terre couverts
quand est pas bien de voir avec la
petite fleur la fois essayer quand même
je vais écrire plus petits pour qu'on
voit ou à la vrt y at il d'autres
possibilités dans un article qui est
resté avec ce nom qui vous retirer des
cartons on va retirer des carburants oui
alors et rachat est ce que ça vous
suffit
ouais
moi j'ai la voici la belle que j'en ai
un et des peines il avait moins tout
quand combien si la pointe aux oies
wassila ben ouais alors vas-y laurent
descos cha cha cha une hutte et chahuté
oui bien à la hausse et jolie ça chat
une si jolie pêche par exemple j'avais
trouvé deux syllabes c'était rapport
c'était bien non rapport et ben voilà on
fait ça servait encore rapport un
rapport oui mais vous êtes dans une
forme
c'est moins bien que tu tant qu'homme
mais vous êtes dans une forme extrême
comme moi qui ai gagné un fabrice oui
c'est vrai et c'est très bien
bravo bravo félicitations à bien tu me
choisit oui une petite led
voilà celle là là oui bon que tu me
désigne son bec
alors alors c'est une petite fille je
crois d'après ce que j'ai vu oui une
petite fille qui s'appelle madeleine
cotonou madeleine cotonou elle habite
paris elle habite dans le 15e
arrondissement
et c'est une lettre qui est adressée
directement à tous quand comme tu peux
le voir rapido c'est ce qu'il me dise où
quand tu n'es pas assez sage fais
attention tu vois
voilà voilà bon alors mais attention à
quoi et bah je ne sais pas elle ajoute
j'aime bien bel bel ainsi que puisque 18
et fabrice je lui fais un baiser à tu
vois ça on lui envoie le disque avec la
chanson et servir rémy
attention attention c'est fini
adressez connais bien alors fabrice
alors je veux tu feras tu remarques
heures et tu es bon dit tu bondi au
tableau oui voilà
bon alors cette fois ci j'ai un mot en
13 lettres
oh non c'est rossi six mois cette
annonce que j'espère que ça va me porter
bonheur 13 est alors bien alors le la
première oui la première c'est un m1
encore m attends à oui alors 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11
après alors enfin dernière 1 1 voilà
alors inutile de te dire que c'est
toujours un moyen de transport
ben oui solitaire et sans la terre et où
il sent la terre prix et de sueur sur
route sur route sur sade et on a oui
c'est à dire oui ça a les roues oui
c'est un moteur et oui il ya un moteur
aussi bizarrement ça 4 ou non non ce
n'est pas 4 à sa deux roues à deux roues
est ce que tu veux une petite lettre
supplémentaire s'il te plaît alors la
quatrième
oui la quatrième c'est un thé un tat
alain 1 1 2 3 4 1 t i see un thé ou un
quatrième semble bien long ça
c'est un deux roues comme tu as dit et
alors que ce ne peut pas être plus de 2
ce récepteur sur cet engin la chance et
en jalles et le casque est obligatoire
ou casque avec deux personnes et une
motocyclette exactement valent encore à
écrire ou motocyclette à motocyclette
comme ça se prononce pas eu tes os et y
6e mais tu conviens avec une auto une
motocyclette ça s'écrit comme ça m
aux photos ah bon ben là pourtant une
auto ça s'écrit bien affûté aux halles
or et c'est pas la même chose
motocyclette et une auto franchement
aulas met la barre encore fait une photo
et mahut moto1 aux théories et brûlant
la moto m'a c'est mon rêve le plus fou
devrait avoir une moto faut être prudent
avec ça tout haut eh oui oui là là là
c'est dangereux quand on la conduit mal
ah oui ah oui eh bien en attendant
allons voir quelle belle un tu veux
qu'on aille voir ben oui je voudrais
bien qu'on s'y amuse toi oui j'ai un
petit peu de temps alors nous allons en
profiter pour jouer à notre petit jeu
musical allait l'arrêter alors je vais
te répond t l'histoire d'une chanson
très connue mais en laissant certains
mots inachevé que tu complétera à l'aide
de notes de musique et à la fin de mon
histoire tu t'apercevras que toutes ces
notes te donne le début de la chanson
question cet amuse mais ce déchet tiens
regarde moi je suis absolument il aa oui
alors mais concentré malgré tout oui
c'est ça qui est intéressant chez toi je
me pense sincèrement que pour deviner la
chance
donc je vais te parler aujourd'hui tu
n'auras pas besoin de beaucoup d'eau ou
tig et de quoi de beaucoup de tontine
des particules ce qu'on va pas sans
écouter me mets dans les oreilles alors
de l'herbe
tu n'auras pas besoin de beaucoup d'eux
a alors activé ou tu vois et bien tu
vois j'aurais voulu que tu hésites je
n'aurais pas me réussit oui c'est une
chanson très très connu dans laquelle il
est question d'un personnage très très
célèbre qui occupe une situation de les
élever au une situation assez part et
quand je dis élevé je veux dire qu'il
passe la plus grande partie de son temps
dans le ciel et qu'ils ne descendent sur
terre qu'en hiver tu vois déjà un petit
fils que joli bond il fait froid qu'il
neige et on se croirait en du berry en
béribéri non en sibérie en sibérie fait
je vis très bien
c'est une chanson qui est aussi une
prière elle pourrait très bien se
terminer par un soit il ainsi soit 1,6
buts mais c'est une prière spéciale
harry on ne l'a fait qu'à une certaine
époque de l'année
à une époque où on offre et où on reçoit
beaucoup de cas cachemire nom de
cacahuètes ou non non pas de cas pas de
cadeaux des cadeaux de cadeaux entre
marché la bresle
enfin j'ajouterai mais ça y est je suis
sûr que tu l'a deviné que cette chanson
est un grand succès de tino euros
rosbif non je n'étais cieux que tu
allais roissy tino rossi
maintenant tu vas pouvoir nous donner
les notes de musique il est joué
alors ce procès n'est ce pas si side
aussi ah oui alors là je démarre remy
emma ah les alors attends oui alors
m
et jouer mameli n'oublie pas mon pénis
voilà un bon single cry of two quant aux
mais je ne l'avais pas vu tellement
j'étais ouvert parmi les mairies
non j'arriverai les saints qui viennent
voter faute il nous a privés cadeaux
[Musique]
tapis
déjà papa d'amy de quatre ans
il me plaît que la vie majeur s'est
désisté et g shock 2 des choses pour les
tomes génie pas de baignoire
il faudra faire attention les quatre
amis sont pas des sorties et qu'axa ni
sont heureux car ils aiment la vie
oui
a mis à jouer aujourd'hui
mes amis vouloir devenir familier
[Musique]